>> WELCOME BACK.
VETERANS ARE FEELING LET DOWN
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S WITHDRAWAL
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
I SPOKE WITH SOME RETIRED
SERVICE MEMBERS.
THEY HAD A LOT TO SAY.
>> FOUR GROWN MEN HERE.
WE HAVE FIVE LEGS.
THAT'S EXTRA SKIN IN THE GAME.
>> MY MIND HAS BEEN CONSUMED
WITH THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS
OF THE BLAST.
THE KNOW THOSE FAMILIES ARE
HURTING IN THE WAY THAT I KNOW
THEY ARE, MAN, IT HURTS.
>> HOW DID IT FEEL TO HAVE A
MARINE GENERAL BE THE ONE TO
ADDRESS THE NATION AND TALK
ABOUT THE TALIBAN THE WAY HE DID
THE DAY WE LEFT?
>> IT'S DISGUSTING.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
POSITIVE EMOTION ABOUT THIS
WHOLE EXPERIENCE.
>> YOU CAN CATCH MY ENTIRE
INTERVIEW THIS WEEKEND ON THE
BIG SATURDAY AND THE BIG SUNDAY
SHOW AT 5:00 P.M. EASTERN.
DAGEN, DO VETERANS FROM
AFGHANISTAN, DO THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO FEEL BETRAYED BY THIS
PRESIDENT?
>> THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO FEEL
BETRAYED OR ANYWAY THEY MIGHT
FEEL BY WHAT THEY HAVE HAD TO
JUST WITNESS IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FEEL FOR THEM.
WE'RE UNITED IN TRYING TO
SUPPORT THEM.
EVERYBODY I KNOW IMMEDIATELY
TEXTING, PHONE CALLS TO PEOPLE
THAT THEY KNEW WHO HAD SERVED
AND MADE IT A POINT.
I FEEL LIKE FOLKS REALIZE THAT
THEY NEED TO DO THAT WITH
EVERYBODY WHO HAS SERVED THIS
COUNTRY.
I THINK WE'RE STRONGER AS A
NATION BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO COME TOGETHER IN THIS MOMENT
OF JUST GRIEF AND RAGE QUITE
FRANKLY.
>> THOSE THREE VETERANS THAT I
SAT DOWN WITH, THEY ALL SERVED
IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS.
TWO DIFFERENT SERVICES, THREE
DIFFERENT JOBS.
THE ONE THAT GOT JOKED UP IS
AMOS BENJAMIN.
HE'S A GOLD STAR BROTHER AND A
PURPLE HEART RECIPIENT.
THIS WAR HAS TAKEN A TOLL ON
THEM.
2,300 DEATHS IN THIS WAR.
13 LAST WEEK ALONG WITH 200
AFGHANS.
SHANNON, DO YOU THINK WE HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO PROCESS HOW
CATASTROPHIC THAT EVENT WAS?
THOSE 13 LIVES, NOT JUST
REFLECTING ON THE WAR BUT THAT
SINGLE EVENT.
I FEEL LIKE THE POLITICS OF IT,
WE HAVEN'T APPRECIATED HOW
CATASTROPHIC THAT DAY WAS.
>> IT'S GOODS TO SEEM PEOPLE SAY
IF YOU KNOW A VETERAN, CHECK ON
THEM.
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THAT SINGLE
EVENT -- THE 20 YEARS WAS SO
BRUTAL AND SO MUCH WAS LOST.
BUT THAT EVENT FELT PREVENTIBLE.
DIDN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN.
SO WE COULD NOT OWE YOU AND OUR
VETERANS A BETTER DEBT.
TO CHECK HOW YOU FEEL, IT WILL
TAKE TIME TO PROCESS THIS.
WHAT HAS BEEN AMAZING TO ME SO
MANY PEOPLE THERE FIGHTING AND
I'M HEARING BACK CHANNELS THAT
THEY'RE VETERANS, PEOPLE RISKING
THEIR OWN LIVES AND EVERY
CONNECTION THAT THEY HAVE,
SPENDING THEIR OWN MONEY TO GET
PEOPLE OUT.
THEY'RE BEING ARRESTED.
THEY'RE STILL RISKS.
OUR VETERANS ARE THE TRUE HEROS.
WE AGREE ON THE THAT.
>> THEY'RE MY HEROS.
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO SERVE.
SEAN, YOU'RE IN CONGRESS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ADMINISTRATIONS.
WHAT CAN CONGRESS DO TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T GET IN THIS AGAIN
OR COULD THEY HAVE DONE
ANYTHING?
>> WE HAVE TROOPS ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
WE SEND PEOPLE ON MISSIONS ALL
THE TIME.
I THINK WITH AFGHANISTAN, A LOT
OF MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THE
COUNTRY LOST FOCUS ON THE FIGHT
AND THE WAR AND THE PURPOSE OF
THE WAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IF YOU'RE
TOING TO SEND MEN AND WOMEN IN
HARM'S WAY, YOU NEVER FORGET
THEIR MISSION.
YOU CONTINUALLY ANALYZE AND
REVIEW TO GO WHAT ARE WE HERE TO
ACCOMPLISH, WHAT IS THE COST IN
LIFE AND TREASURE AND MAKE
DECISIONS FROM THERE.
THIS IS A MESSAGE TO CONGRESS TO
ALWAYS STAY TUNE WITH THE MONEY
THAT YOU SEND AND THE MEN THAT
YOU SEND IN THESE CONFLICTS.
FOR ME, FOUR GUYS.
FIVE LEGS.
THAT IS HORRIFIC.
I HAVE A BUT DID IN WISCONSIN,
LUMBER JACK CHAMPION.
HIT BY A ROAD SAME BOMB AS WELL.
LOST HALF OF HIS ARM.
CAME BACK AFTER AND WON THE LOG
ROLLING TITLE.
THEY'RE AMAZING.
THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE WAR HAS
BEEN CATACLYSMIC.
THE WAY WE LEFT MAKES A LOT OF
VET TRANS ANGRY BECAUSE THE
QUESTION COMES FOR WHAT?
WHAT WAS THE END GOAL?
>> WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN STANDS
UP THERE AND INVOKES OUR MENTAL
HEALTH FOR HIS JUSTIFICATION FOR
DECISIONS, HIS ENTIRE LAST TWO
WEEKS, ISN'T THAT TONE DEAF?
DOESN'T HE UNDERSTAND WHAT
SEEING 13 VETERANS KILLED AND
FEELING HELPLESS TO HEALTH?
DOES HE NOT SEE THE CONNECTION
THERE?
>> I CAN NOT SUPPOSE TO
UNDERSTAND ANY EXPERIENCE THAT
YOU'VE HAD, THE MEN WHO YOU
TALKED TO OR THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO SERVE FOR US.
WE'RE ALL SO THANKFUL FOR THAT.
I THINK EVERYONE -- WE DO THIS
THING WHERE YOU QUARTERBACK ON
TWITTER, SOCIAL MEDIA.
THERE'S THE JOKES THE MORNING
AFTER.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT WE'RE ALL
WOKE UP TO BE FOREIGN POLICY
EXPERTS OR VETERANS.
THERE'S ONE GROUP THAT STANDS
OUT FROM THE REST THAT WE WOKE
UP AND IT'S VETERANS.
YOU NOTICED IT IN THE COVERAGE.
EVERY TIME NO MATTER WHAT THE
OPINION IS OF THE PERSON DOING
THE INTERVIEW IF THEY HEAR FROM
A VETERAN, IT IS RUNNING COUNTER
TO WHAT THE HOST THINKS, YOU
SHUT UP.
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE THAT NONE OF
US CAN TOUCH AND IT WILL BE WITH
YOU THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
SERVE, CONTINUE TO SERVE, THEY
SERVE IN WASHINGTON AND IN THESE
INCREDIBLE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE GOTTEN PEOPLE OUT THAT
WOULDN'T HAVE GROTTEN THEM OUT
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
A LOT OF RESPECT AND THANKS TO
YOU AND THOSE MEN YOU
INTERVIEWED AND EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT SERVES.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
VETERANS RUNNING FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WE HAVE BEEN.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
>> EVEN MORE.
>> THAT'S WHAT GOT PEOPLE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
I HAVE A BUDDY OVER THERE STILL
THAT I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM.
I THINK HE'S ALL RIGHT.
HE'S PROBABLY DOING GOD'S WORK.
>> TELL US WHAT WE'LL HEAR ABOUT
THIS WEEKEND.
>> THESE THREE VETERANS, ONE IS
THE NEFF YOU OF GEORGE W. BUSH.
HE'S THE MOST NORMAL BUSH I'VE
MET.
HIS NAME IS WALTER BUSH.
>> SO IF YOU'RE NAME IS BUSH
YOU'RE NOT NORMAL?
>> I MET HIM.
HE GOES HOW IS YOUR HEAD?
HE WAS IN THE DROP THE D
CAMPAIGN.
AND AMOS BENJAMIN A GOLD STAR
BROTHER.
YOU HAVE CHAD FLEMING, A REAL
JASON BORNE STYLE CHARACTER.
AN AMPUTEE IN WORLD.
EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM IS
LEADERSHIP.
THEY COME FROM DIFFERENT PLACES.
YOU WATCH THE INTERVIEW AND THEY
HAVE THEIR HEAD HUNG THE WHOLE
TIME.
IT'S A TOUGH THING.
THEY HAVE INSPIRING WORDS BY THE
END.
>> ON BEHALF OF VETERANS, THANK
YOU.
MEANS A LOT.
IT DOES.
>> I'M PRAYING ON IT.
PRAY EVERY DAY.
SHANNON BREAM DOES, TOO.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
>> YOU CAN CATCH MY ENTIRE